my guest tonight is a comedian and an
actor who was of course a cast member on
silent live
he's also starred in the horrible bosses
movies and we're
the millers now you can see him in the
series ted lasso
on apple tv plus please welcome jason
sedakis jason how are you yes sir i'm
well
you know all things considered yeah yeah
you i'm
i i'm i'm doing well i like you know i
but the big thing for me is the hair is
out of control now
and yeah i feel like i feel like i gotta
match it there like
look at that yeah you got a lot going on
too might as well
we're both gonna do it let's do it yeah
all right well i have
you know i feel like we've done this
before i don't expect you to remember
that because you've talked to a lot of
people but i've only
i've only you know yeah i've talked to a
lot of people and i'm also a sociopath
who has no recollection of my human
interactions
let me begin jason by praising your show
i watched i binge watched the entire
season and i loved it and i watched it
with my son and we were both just
completely loving i love the character
of ted lasso it's really fantastic
thanks man that means the absolute world
to me i'm so flattered and i love that
you watched it with your with your uh
your son that's great yeah you know
what's so nice is we're in this dark
time
and what what i'm responding to is the
show is really funny
but also the character of ted lasso is
so optimistic
that i sort of feel like he's the hero
we need right now that's what i'm taking
away from the show like that's the guy
who i think can get me through covid i i
appreciate that i i mean
you know what's crazy to me is is the
fact that
there's an argument to be made that
maybe we could have used this guy you
know
four or five years ago too yeah maybe
but right
um but like this whole idea was
conceived
at least for the show in 2015 and my
my my joke had been you know leading up
to
the show finally you know existing much
less premiering is
the big pill you had to swallow as far
as the high concept of it being like a
show about a guy
who could ever believe a show about a
guy who has no idea what he's doing
being in charge of something as
important as a professional soccer team
and like now nobody nobody's everybody's
just like
yeah yeah this is great this is exactly
like
nobody cares right now
you're trying to set that the stakes are
really high that he's taking over a
mediocre professional uh you know soccer
team
in england and by today's standards
that's absolutely nothing
you know yeah it's like oh you'll let
that go
i love the show i want to talk about the
show in a minute but i want to first
find out
how you're doing in quarantine i'm
finding that i'm getting more kid time
is that the same with you yeah
absolutely yeah i mean and it and it
sucks
right no no it's been you know listen to
your people it's hard
i'm not a fan of my family uh yeah i
don't like them
and i find them off-putting yeah no
exactly
and and knowing that i'm 50 responsible
for how off-putting they are is real
humbling
i think you're not i think you're 80
responsible
certainly with my daughter you know i've
met your wife she's lovely
uh no you're you may be 90 responsible
for any negative qualities
i'm louder it's just because i'm louder
i take up more space that's all
but but yeah no we've been we've been
getting after it you know it's it's you
know
our kids are uh otis is the uh sixth
daisy's four
and they um yeah it's been a lot of well
with otis i've been taking them through
the classics we
we you know we've been doing star wars
and oh you watch the you watch the
classic movies that's great we
yeah we're taking we're taking them
through that because that's that's i'm
no i'm not a good
teacher you know i i was never good at
even when i taught improv
at teaching level one i i was i was not
i'm not ted lasso
in that way he's he's a much better
person and teacher and leader and coach
than i am
but um you know going through starting
with you know the phantom menace and
working through we're
our next one is empire strikes back but
it's been a super fun way
and very interesting way to teach and
i'm sure numerous people know this to
teach good and evil
to your kids like and just
how much they care and how much you know
to to have your
little boy like sit there and watch
anakin skywalker get more and more angry
as this you know this palpatine dude is
like you know putting you know
whispering things in his ear i mean
and i and i kind of have to be i'm
watching it with the eyes of like what's
going on in the news today i'm like oh
yeah
no palpatine's the son of a [ __ ] he
would absolutely be getting rid of
mailboxes right now
i see what i see with this slick mf
you're trying to pull
i get it i see this coming a mile away
that's a great that's a great way to
teach your kids morality i did it when
my kids were really little i made them
watch goodfellas
and uh yeah and i just basically so that
they could learn
that uh if the mob wants to take over
your restaurant
don't do it because they're gonna sell
and it was
it not the good lessons they needed to
learn not as clear-cut
as what you're talking about it's good
fellas not good lessons right i mean
that's
that's you know it's right there in the
title but we just watched e.t
this weekend we started too late on
saturday night thinking oh we'll do you
know wait till the dark
uh but boy our little guy
freaked out he was so sad when when the
when the spaceship spoiler
spoilers everybody if you haven't seen
et uh but when the spaceship takes off
and leaves e.t
on earth he freaked out in a way that
was like
i i mean i felt again 80 responsible as
i've never done that to you i got
immediately defensive right it's like he
like went to his bed it was just like
it's just so sad it was mostly because
he was tired because he watched it the
next day
and the whole time trying to figure out
daisy is hilarious daisy when
when like peter coyote's character shows
up with the keys and he's kind of
ominous you don't know who he is
she's just like uh oh here come the cops
she knows that at what age she's three
and a half
right oh boy here come the cops there we
go hide the weed
she has all these outdated ideas yeah
speaking of kids
are your kids aware that you played a
stormtrooper in the mandalorian do they
know because that would give you the
ultimate street cred i would think
otis is definitely we didn't we haven't
watched mandalorian we're not doing the
full
universe just the you know the nine
films so he hasn't watched mandalorian
yet but
um he got to come to set that day um
when i when
myself and adam pauly who i know you
know we got we got that call
like i mean yeah man like the the
six to ten year old boy in me was like
yes i'll do it absolutely
and then the fact that it eventually
came out that i um
that when that thing aired and my
character as does adam's you know
punches
baby yoda yes i was gonna talk about
this that hasn't come up yet i don't
think
they don't know that yet but let's talk
about this the entire
internet came down on top of you because
uh your character you as the
stormtrooper
you punch baby yoda we have that scene
right now
let's take a look waiting confirmation
knock it off and there you go
down there there it was yeah uh what
else
did you improvise that please tell me
that i
yeah i wish
that's what you do when you see a baby
exactly just just
just haul off on a great santini style
no
like the craziest thing about that is is
you know i
did this that thing months earlier and
it was you know one afternoon
you know again truly dream come true
dressing up like that
doing it it was coming down and then
went away and then did a hundred other
things you know
you know writing the ted lasso show
shooting the tele all this stuff you
know life goes on
and then they they rolled those episodes
out you know one at a time
and lotus and i was sitting in here you
know playing video games or something
i forget on a saturday or sunday morning
and olivia comes in with her phone and
she goes hey you're trending on twitter
i was like oh how about that and i don't
i'm not on you know twitter like uh
actively in that way and so immediately
i was like wait why
you know in today's age it's like wait
am i dead did i die
am i canceled what happened uh and it
was that i was being canceled in real
time that was like you
hit baby yoda and i had like that moment
like like the end of sixth sense or rat
tattooey where i'm just like
oh right i should have been able to
anticipate two and a half months earlier
when baby yoda became like the
belle of the ball you know on the
internet and everything everybody talked
about it didn't even it did i
i totally forgot that oh yeah i backhand
this little this little uh
you haul off you really wail on baby
yoda and
yeah yeah i'm it's that's a career
i think that's a career killer i'm sorry
you would think you would think but
but but because you couldn't see my face
because people
you know i can always say that it was
you know
that that they they manipulated that i
didn't know they were going to do that i
you know see they've cpr your arm
that's what yeah exactly like i'll be
damned how did that happen yeah
so yeah i'm still dealing with it but i
but you know i know what jim gaffin's
going through
i get it i get it
you know i wanted to bring this up uh
you know everyone of course obsessed as
we have to be
with kovid yeah and what we're all
dealing with with covet and everyone's
constantly trying to figure out oh my
god my throat hurts
could i possibly um
you actually uh one of the main symptoms
for kobe that everyone knows is not
having a sense of smell
yeah yeah you have never had a sense of
smell is that right
that is true you were born without a
sense of smell
as far as i know because i don't
remember ever being able to smell so i
think it was congenital although
something may have happened so i i mean
i didn't i wasn't like a very um
i didn't fall and hit my head a lot like
i wasn't like a um
a fearless kid you know like kids that
you know climb up things i mean i did
break an arm but i don't remember having
a head injury
so as far as i know it's yeah i've never
had it and
you know yeah and now here it is being a
thing so when i
even mentioned to people that don't know
me or or something um
you know i'm like oh i can't smell like
it'll just come out they're like oh are
you are you worried it's like oh no i've
never been able to smell
right and people are kind of like oh oh
never mind but it is a question like
wait how
then you get the questions you know what
can you taste and it's like
you know no but but i don't have nuance
there's so many little subtleties that
i've learned as i've gotten older
and i didn't even realize it all growing
up because as a kid the only thing you
really pay attention to
what smells is like you know something
like pizza or cookies or farts
you know but then at some point when i
was doing second city and i was in the
touring company so
we're in like a nine passenger bus or a
van and we're traveling around you know
going from chicago to like ohio state or
something and you pass through a um
there were two things i remember going
past like some field or farm
and everybody was like oh roll up the
windows because it smelled like cow [ __ ]
or something
and then once those windows were up
there was i remember there being another
moment where people like oh
today because do you have your shoes off
i was like yeah i was like laying down
in the back seat they're like will you
put them on please i didn't realize i
had the stinkiest feet
on earth and that that you kind of had
no idea had no idea and it stayed with
me
my first couple years at snl at some
point it kind of like
went away i don't know how or what i
didn't necessarily address it in a
you know meaningful way but it kind of
disappeared but early on
um the felt you know tom and eric over
at snl they would put my sneakers in a
tupperware
because in a tupperware like my yeah
and again i had no idea and it's super
it was super duper embarrassing
but um but they found a way to make it
less embarrassing for me and more
importantly to make it less
more tolerable for them yeah and then
yeah i i've got nothing i i it's uh
it's toxic waste you know yeah oh 100
but but
but like my little girl uh daisy she
just last week realized that otis found
this out ages ago
but she um we had a couple olive trees
like in our front yard
and she grabbed a bunch of leaves and
she was like smelling like that
and she was daddy smell and i'm like i
can't smell it she was no no smell
and i go up and i go like that i go yeah
nothing and she's like no no you gotta
go like this
i'm like no no honey i am and it was it
was like you know like a comedy routine
and
she's just like looking at me and
doesn't get it but to see your little
kid be able to do something that you
can't do
and and have a sense of like a memory
of it is is bizarre you know i mean i
can't touch my toes either but
smell you'd think i'd still be able to
do you'll come back i swear to god
go come back at least when you least
expect it
yeah but i mean if you had to lose one
one cents out of your five which one
would you lose
which would you choose i think my sense
of justice
oh no okay well you know we're getting
there then i could act with impunity all
the time
right you can take you you can get to
the highest heights that way yeah
apparently it doesn't it doesn't hold
you back uh
we have a clip here from uh ted last so
i want to show this
do you want to set it up in any way or
do you want you want help with this sure
i i believe it's from uh our fifth
episode so yeah uh
ted is um his wife and kid are coming
over
to uh to visit and so he's just talking
to
his boss um which is the character
rebecca welton played by hannah
wattingham uh deftly she's great great
yeah
you know she's did you watch game of
thrones yeah yeah you know she's the gal
the shame the nun shame no there she is
isn't that great that's the [ __ ] that's
i didn't know that yeah that's fine
i didn't know that because we were like
the only couple that didn't watch game
of thrones so when when she came in for
the audition and i was like oh she's
fantastic what else has she done
and people are like oh she's this and i
know it just as like a gift
i know that character is a gift but yeah
you know she looks completely different
uh
as any of us can do with the yeah she is
your uh she owns the team
and she has hired you and we find out
more about why she hired you but uh
it's you guys are terrific culture clash
throughout yes
so that's what this scene is let's think
of this uh take a look at this clip from
ted lasso
good morning ted hey
i mean it's my fault for staring at my
phone
i just can't stop checking on my
family's flight you know i haven't
shared this with too many folks but um
michelle and i we've been having some
marital issues ted
you really don't have to talk about this
if you don't want to why don't mine
tried couples therapy didn't like the
other couple though
oh it feels good to laugh yeah you know
our therapist gave us this code word to
use so if either of us says
oklahoma the other one has to tell the
god's honest truth
yeah you know it's pretty helpful did
ruin the musical for me though
so now every time i hear oh what a
beautiful morning or uh
what sorry with the fringe on top or
chubby dumps
no that's from king and i anyway if i
hear any of those tunes
i immediately think about my wife
telling me that my constant optimism is
too much and we're back there we go
see how i did that it was amazing just a
little head like a little head moving
you dip right back into it
yeah um no seriously i i
i cannot uh more strongly suggest a
television show right now because it
really is
it's uplifting it's really funny and uh
sweet
and uh i really think people are gonna
love it uh who haven't seen it yet
new episodes of ted lasso are available
every friday on apple tv
plus so uh i'm really looking forward to
because and i'm i'm hooked so
yeah we i i want you to go make more
right now in your backyard
i i i can shoot little things you know
it'll be a little sloppy um
but uh you know and he'll he'll be on a
bender
ted will be on a bender because he's got
his beard but then you know thank you so
much for doing this i really appreciate
it
no of course thanks for having me as
always it's always great to see and chat
with you